three to five years from now there will
not be a distinction between the
internet and television and we'll just
be entertainment and media that's all
will be it will be all on demand it will
be all on one screen and you'll have a
hard drive and that hard drive will be a
combination of your old tivo stuff
itunes hulu it's all available you might
pay for something you might pay for a
subscription the way I do with 30 rock i
am going to cancel my cable subscription
there's no point for me to have it but
you'll also have a lot of additional
features there'll be no reason to have
set programming like 30 minutes 44 well
actually it's like 20 it's like 22
minutes 44 minutes that's how they do it
no reason some shows will remain like
that because it's simply habit however
you will find that you'll have episodic
shows like the guild which has gotten a
lot of attention on YouTube very well
written webisodes tiny huge huge fan
base what's going to happen is that
there will be a huge shift in production
costs so instead of shifting the
business model which actually there will
be a small shift in the business model
too but the production costs have got to
go way way down a lot of television
executives don't think that can happen
it's not true I have done it I have
worked with magazines that have no money
but they need video content it is
possible and viewers are so much more
willing to watch low production value
stuff than anyone realizes so when the
Mart you know it's just you might keep
the margins the same but the production
costs have to go way way down the other
thing that's going to happen is instead
of strict advertisements or product
placement you're going to have
old-school sponsorships the way that
radio did back in the 30s you know this
program is sponsored by Colgate you're
going to see a ton of that that's what
next new networks is really bringing
right now to web and it's going to be
targeted sponsorships not random stuff
it's like they're
the advertisers are going to be thinking
about what makes sense they're going to
be spending less money but they're going
to be targeting people in a in a more
careful way instead of spending 30
million dollars on American Idol they'll
be spending 3 million dollars but
they're going to be getting the exact
same number of customers which means
that the television networks which are
just going to become entertainment
networks have got to be smarter about it
and the great news is then we won't have
to suffer through terrible programming
that is dumb down for everyone